the thing that you're dreaming of doing
being a singer being a content creator
whatever it is if you never jump you've
always lost if you jump you might lose
but you've always known you did it
that's a big difference because if you
don't jump It's a guaranteed loss if you
do jump five percent of you might pull
it off but for the 95 that don't at
least you don't have to live your life
but that pit in your stomach that you
never went
attention and build businesses
greater than currency
what is going on at Sunday at the
national at the V Friendswood you know
how Sunday is it's chill I'm kind of
walking around buying I'm watching kids
literally play the TCG right now
um really starting to establish this IP
we're building slowly but we put a flag
on the ground of building the be friends
brand and I'm proud of that people are
discovering the characters and we've got
a long road to building out this IP but
I'm a minute for that I like the grind I
like the building and we'll be doing
that I'm having a very good time
today's updates live here at the
National Car convention remember this
strangers become acquaintances
acquaintances become friends and Friends
become family and I really believe in
that Journey like we don't pick our
parents we don't pick our siblings but
all of us we pick our friends yeah and
they always start off as strangers yeah
and so be more open don't be scared love
yourself give yourself some Freedom
don't beat yourself up love yourself
because if you love yourself you'll have
room to love others and that's what
we're saying
Eileen and revenue my first year and
congratulations first book I ever read
that got me started crushing it
everybody's watching do what she did she
had the courage to jump even if the
thing that you're dreaming of doing
being a singer being a content creator
or being a breaker whatever it is if you
never jump you've always lost if you
jump you might lose but you've always
known you did it that's a big difference
because if you don't jump It's a
guaranteed loss if you do jump five
percent of you might pull it off but for
the 95 that don't at least you don't
have to live your life but that pit in
your stomach that you never went
thank you you're welcome
man I'm sad we're leaving this is how
gen I am I literally just said man I
hate that we're leaving because I'm
looking at supplies for trading cards
and it made me feel sad and nostalgic
with perfect timing we're at mascot we
just did the podcast and he's eating I
mean this is it like out of all the
seconds of the entire show to walk it
keep eating all of you over listening in
the podcast I told you he's handsome no
what what was the big standout
the amount of kids here the amount of
activity I drop by your booth hundreds
of hundreds of people every single time
I drop by now the important question
what is the best potato chip flavor
I wanted
oh Italian ice this entire show brother
we'll see you in Cleveland let's keep
this going rolling the supplies I'm
telling you this is the backbone of the
industry you don't have your
right your dad supplies are
underrated Brandon knows how much I nerd
out on supplies what's been your most
awesome pickup this week I got a Ronaldo
bgs 8.5 Mega crafts rookie which I'm
excited about I'm buying some of the
Vintage non-sport stuff because I'm
building an intellectual property some
of the Disney some of the He-man some of
the you know cool pop culture stuff's
got my attention Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles so I'm enjoying it
we're talking about
okay we're wrapping up here
car is packed back to New York just had
the best time time with my friends time
with my co-workers who are my family and
uh really expanded the brand you know
this is fun there's not a lot of video
on the early vaynermedia stuff there's
not a lot there's no video on the early
Wine Library stuff but there's gonna be
a lot of video on the early beaver and
stuff and
I'm excited I'm excited you're on this
journey dust it was fun and uh I really
hope that
you all can find something you like
building as much as I'm enjoying
building be friends
um it's a great joy It's a Grind it's
hard
I don't know how Dustin team are gonna
edit this but there was a lot of energy
put out every day second by second by
second and uh it's well worth it because
it's gonna be fun
it's for everyone see ya
[Music]
foreign